hi it's larry herb xbox live's major
nelson here with richard irving from the
xbox engineering team richard great to
see you again thank you always great to
be here now we are here to talk about
the features coming to Xbox one in the
August update what do we have to look
forward to the August update is a pretty
big update for social and community
engagement the first feature is the
Activity Feed we've revamped the
Activity Feed to really focus the items
appearing in your feed to to the things
that you care most about achievements
earned by your friends game DVR clips
new friend relationships and we're also
making it longer so we can include more
items in the feed and you can really
scroll back pretty far in time to see
really the history of what your friend
network has been up to I've also noticed
here we can see it here at least in the
video is that there's also some other
things you've added to the Activity Feed
well so we've made the activity feed
more interactive
and so you have the ability now to like
items in the feed okay you have the
ability to comment on them and when your
friends comment on items in your feed
you'll be notified of that so you can
see what's popular amongst your friends
but even cooler than that is you can
share game DVR clips from your activity
feed to another activity feed and
promote them across all of your friends
or you can share them as an attachment
in an Xbox Live message to specific
friends where at where else can I use
that functionality well the upload app
so when you're using the upload app
you'll see game DVR clips and be able to
like them from within there as well so
we also one of the most requested
features I've seen for a while mobile
purchases that's right in the August
update using either SmartGlass or xbox
calm you will be able to buy games and
add-ons and when you have your home
console configured for instant on and
background updates when you buy that
item it will power on just enough to
download and install so that it's ready
to play when you get home all right I
like that all right moving right along
here we have a cool news about some
couple of notifications so also fan
feedback around notifications the first
is being able to disable notifications
during video playback so when you're
watching TV or you're in full screen
video you can disable notifications from
appearing sometimes you don't feel like
playing a game you just maybe on a date
night or watching a big game you don't
want to be interrupted this will now not
interrupt you that's right and then when
you go back to playing a game or you go
out to home you'll get you'll get
notifications again they shall resume
what else do we have so we have a low
battery notification so when your
wireless controller is low on power it
reaches a critical level you'll get a
notification telling you that it's low
on battery and you should change them as
quickly as possible to avoid the
controller shutting off in the middle of
gameplay that's all great stuff Richard
you also have a little preview of what
we can expect in the future right so
earlier this year we did with the one
guide we did an extended preview for
some of the some of the features on
smart glass and now we're doing an
extended preview on the console for an
update to home so we're introducing a
friend's area on home that will
show you at a glance what your friends
are up to the most popular games amongst
your friends and even a gamer score
leaderboard to inspire some competition
some healthy competition amongst your
friends so that you can see how you're
doing compared to your friends at
earning more gamerscore and it's going
to stay in preview until our preview
audience has given us the feedback and
we've had a chance to digest and respond
to it so when it's generally available
it's exactly the way we want it that is
awesome Richard Irving thank you for
walking us through what's coming in
august and a little preview about what's
coming laters here thank you Richard
thank you